many European powers took a role in the
Scramble for Africa and came away with
sizable amounts of land the French and
the British got the lion's share was
Portugal Spain Germany and Italy were
also represented one nation whose
position as an imperial power might seem
slightly out of place though that of
Belgium Belgium was not at this point
nor had it ever been a great imperial
power at the end of the nineteenth
century had a population of about six
and a half million people which compared
to the other nations who grabbed chunks
of Africa wasn't very much
Belgium's army was much smaller than its
neighbors and his Navy consisted of
exactly zero warships this raises the
question how did Belgium gain an empire
and one so rich and resources at that
surely the competing powers of Europe
would have wanted its territory for
themselves then there wasn't much Bodrum
could have done about it anyway right
well in order to answer the question we
unsurprisingly need to look at the
Scramble for Africa itself and why the
nations of Europe decided to divide it
up the way that they did so the Scramble
for Africa was supposed to divvy up the
continent amongst the European powers in
order to prevent conflict with each
other in the end it was divided up like
this and Belgium was given access to
this land known as the Congo well sort
of what it actually happened was that
all of the European powers had wanted
the Congo because money the problem was
that none of them could agree on who
would get it which made conflict more
likely and to king leopold ii of belgium
who had a wonderful idea
i'll have it and strangely enough
nations like Germany France and Britain
agreed that he could have it he not
Belgium he as in the Congo was now the
personal property of Leopold he was
granted it under the condition that
trade of its natural resources mostly
rubber would be open to all nations that
way everyone could gain some of the
resources there and it would be under
the administration of a king whose
nation was constitutionally bound to be
permanently neutral Leopold also
convinced the European powers that he
would do everything in his power to
Christianize the Congo and the slave
trade in the region and better the lives
of the people there instead of doing
that he created a place in which if the
Congolese failed to meet their rubber
production quotas the punishment was
death or sometimes mutilation the reason
I mentioned this is that Leopold's poor
treatment of the Congolese would go on
to become a problem for him and threaten
his ownership of the colony so all of
this explains how Leopold gained an
empire but not Belgium itself the
aforementioned terrible treatment of the
natives led to an immense amount of
international criticism mostly from the
United States and Britain as such in
1908 the Belgian Parliament opted to
annex the Congo on behalf of Belgium
itself
this upset Leopold but he wouldn't have
to be upset for long since the next year
he came down with the case of the deads
so now Belgium owned the Congo simple
right well no the first thing that
Belgium did after annexing the colony
was to close down trade whilst reforms
were undertaken which shockingly upset
the British as such Britain refused to
acknowledge the annexation and many
Belgium were concerned that Britain was
going to try and see some of the Congo
for itself which is only partially true
Britain didn't want at all but there
were discussions about either taking or
forcibly purchasing these lands to make
the Belgians much more nervous the 1911
Agadir crisis kicked off which or
Germany demands some sort of
compensation for the French annexation
of Morocco France gave Germany this land
in central Africa and both agreed that
maybe the borders there weren't exactly
set in stone it looked like Belgium's
Empire was to be short-lived until they
did something very clever it started to
flirt with Germany and for Britain and
France this would be a disaster
because in the event of war it could
lead to Belgium missing German troops
through into France and wouldn't give
Britain the leeway to intervene as such
Britain folded in in June 1913 they
recognized the annexation of Congo and
Belgium's interest there after labour
France and Britain Belgium would get to
keep its empire I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
extra thanks to my patrons that you see
on screen now and a special thanks to
James Bissonnette izalco flash mark H
party-boy Co David archaeologist Rob
Waterhouse Chris wicker Michael Reynolds
Gustav Swan onion Duck David Silverman
Paul Maggie packs Kowski Winston K wood
vasily era vedas christian check hey
Anthony Beckett Skye Chappell Adam
Harvey and Ike